foreign
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number
191. two two
I'm Dr Brett Weinstein this is Dr
Heather hurrying I have just returned
from a trip to hell I went to hell I am
now back welcome back thank you
um I had a run-in with the coronavirus
and I know that the variant that is
circulating currently is supposed to be
very mild that was not my experience my
experience was quite profound I should
say I did not test positive I took six
tests including a PCR never came out
positive but the symptoms were so Square
on the money that the nurse who saw me
and the doctor with whom I'm I consulted
agree with me that it really had to be
Coronavirus
um but anyway watch yourselves out there
it's still out there it's not a good
disease it isn't especially deadly I
never feared I was gonna die but
um man it was not pleasant you were not
well I was not well yeah and you're
still recovering
um as such
um well we are going to cram in a number
of live streams here to accommodate the
missing ones and to accommodate upcoming
travel as well
um we are not going to do any q and A's
uh for the um until otherwise noted and
I'm going to read all the ads today
um and and like that so I'm going to
respond to each of the ads with a single
word that sums up my feelings excellent
that way I will do it is uh it's a
threat oh no no I take it as a promise
all right all right it's a promise all
right so uh join us join us on Rumble
join us on locals uh these are uh
organizations that are fiercely Pro
fiercely Pro free speech fiercely free
speech and uh right now we are streaming
on Rumble
and our watch party is on locals um at
our locals station channel
uh community community thank you uh and
and also at our locals we have our
private monthly q a which we had to
delay last week but we'll be doing this
upcoming Sunday we do uh Zach and I did
a live AMA last uh last Wednesday which
I think is available right that's that's
available so um you get to see our
producer and me answering questions uh
uh just a week ago now and uh and
there's gonna be Discord servers up
there anyway please join us on locals
and join us on Rumble and support these
um awesome platforms
we are going to talk about uh cows today
yes we are and I'll just leave it at
that and a number of other things as
well we always have sponsors at the top
of the hour we are very grateful to our
sponsors they help us do what we do and
we are very choosy about whom we accept
so if you hear us read ads for sponsors
for products that are of interest to you
here you can be assured that we are
actually vouching for them without
further Ado here we go
it's MD hearing this week Sundays and
Seed our first sponsor this week is MD
hearing
we have friends and family who have
hearing loss we do not there's a good
chance that you do too have friends and
family who have hearing loss well we
don't have need for hearing aids
ourselves we have a good friend who does
and we have asked her to assess MD
hearings newest product carefully and
honestly she also did an assessment of a
previous version her testimonial is at
the end of this ad MD hearing makes high
quality simple and effective hearing
aids for a tiny fraction of what most
hearing aids cost helping bring audio
Clarity and capacity to people who might
not otherwise be able to afford it MD
hearing was founded by an ENT surgeon
who made his mission to develop a
quality hearing aid that anyone could
afford he keeps price Low by simplifying
the product removing several rarely
needed components MD hearing's new Neo
model Cuts costs over 90 percent less
than Clinic hearing aids and the Neo is
empty hearing smallest hearing aid ever
it fits inside your ear and no one will
even know it's there
other features include rechargeable
batteries that last up to 30 hours and
water resistance and up to three feet of
water in their volt plus model you don't
need a prescription which also means
there's no middleman another cost-saving
measure MD hearing is now offering high
quality rechargeable digital hearing
aids for only for 149.99 each when you
buy a pair that's 300 for a pair of
hearing aids here's the newest
testimonial from our friend who has
substantial hearing loss and who relies
on hearing aids we asked her to try this
product and this is what she said I
tested the Neo the new in the ear canal
hearing aids offered by MD hearing I was
a bit skeptical since I've never liked
the in I've never liked in the ear canal
model she says preferring the stability
of over the years since they were
surprisingly comfortable and stable
staying put without coming loose even
when I wore them to exercise I tried the
Neo in several situations from Discord
voice chat to an in-person conversation
in a room with a white noise generator
and they passed every test it is true
they don't have the individual audiogram
programming and smartphone integration
of my usual hearing aids but they have
everything else for less than five
percent of the price they provide an
absolutely stunning level of quality for
pennies on the dollar so
This Is Us now not her anymore if you
want MD hearing smallest hearing aid yet
go to mdhearingaid.com and use promo
code Darkhorse to get their new buy one
get one deal they are 149.99 each when
you buy a pair plus Dark Horse listeners
receive a free extra charging case a
hundred dollar value head to
mdhearingaid.com and use our promo code
Darkhorse and get their new buy one get
one 149.99 each offer when you buy a
pair absolutely
terrible all right but it's terrible I'm
not fully well I'm still recovering so I
mean it wasn't bad no it was terrible it
was in the right direction for those of
you who are tuning in in the middle
Brett promised because I'm going to read
all the ads this week on account of his
uh his his voice going in and out um to
uh offer a single word uh explanation of
my feelings upon your completion of the
end which I did
hearing is awesome they are off Brett's
one word summary was terrible oh my God
that's pretty meta though the evaluation
of my summary being fair to middling oh
no it wasn't fair to Middle like it was
awful oh all right
that was great inflation on my part yes
yes
um an experience with it but you have
very little very no experience at all
I'm the opposite yes I did yeah over and
over and over again anyway our second
sponsor this week is Maddie's all-time
favorite you can see a little piece of
her in the background but not much not
at all now it's entirely my face on the
screen apparently uh we love it too
because what dog owner and dog lover
doesn't love a product that is great for
their dog their dog thinks is great too
Sundays makes dry dog food when they
approach us about being a sponsor we
were dubious Maddie our dog a labrador
um will basically eat anything what
possible difference was she going to
show an interest between her usual
kibble a widely available high-end brand
and Sundays we were wrong
Maddie loves the food that Sundays makes
she loves it if we run out of Sundays
and give her previous hind kibble
instead she's clearly disappointed in us
although being a lab she doesn't want to
show that but if you've got a lab you
now have devastating it can be when your
dog actually shows disappointment in you
she knows that we can do better we can
give her some days and we should not
only is Sunday's Maddie's favorite it is
also far better for her than the
standard burnt kibble that rises most
dried dog food Sundays is the first and
only human grade air dried dog food air
drying combines the best of cooked and
raw approaches like raw air drying
preserves nutrients and tastes better
than high heat methods better than raw
though Sunday's unique air drying
process includes a kill step which kills
pathogens unlike freeze dried raw or
frozen raw dog foods there is no food
safety or handling risk with Sundays
combining the nutrition and taste of all
natural human grade foods with the ease
of a zero prep ready to eat formula
Sundays is an amazing way to feed your
dog there's no fridge no prep no cleanup
no gross wet dog food smells it's a
total pleasure for the human interacting
with it which is a bonus
Sundays has no artificial binders
synthetic additives or general garbage
seriously look at the label all of
Sunday's ingredients are easy to
pronounce and healthy for dogs to eat
in a blind taste test Sunday's
outperformed leading competitors 42-0
and our own little anecdote Maddie our
Labrador supports that results when I
have a bowl of Sundays ready for her
it's a whole different level of
enthusiasm from her usual enthusiasm for
food which is already high she bounces
and Spins and leaps in anticipation do
you want to make your dog happy with
your diet keep her healthy try Sundays
we've got a special deal for our
listeners receive 35 off your first
order go to sundays4dogs.com Darkhorse
or use code Darkhorse at checkout that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash Darkhorse switch to Sundays and
feel good about what you are feeding
your dog delicious
that better that's that's better okay
um yep and you would know I'm one of
very few Who would know or very no I'm
one of many Who would know but when a
few who would report out yeah no I'll
bet especially after you admitted that
you had tasted it others also tasted it
they probably did no I was thinking that
most of those who know are actually dogs
who do not report out but no they don't
yeah
but I do yeah and there once again we
have a little little Sheaf of dog behind
us
okay our final sponsor this week is seed
a probiotic that really works if you've
tried probiotics before and got nothing
out of it try seed it's designed
differently from other probiotics it's
designed better it actually works you've
got your immune system worked together
coordinating your body's response to the
world both around and within you see it
helps improve the health of your gut
microbiome which means that it supports
you becoming healthier overall
our resonant gut microbes
are resident gut microbes directly
impact the development and function of
the immune system even before we're born
microbes inform our immune system
teaching our body how to distinguish
between benign substances and pathogenic
antigens that is substances that your
body does not recognize as its own
you can support your gut immune access
in a variety of ways including for
instance by prioritizing sleep new
research suggests the gut
microbiome has its own circadian clock
and that changes to your normal rhythms
can disrupt your microbes and the
important functions they perform
prioritizing regular sleep can thus help
keep your gut immune axis healthy and I
will say I'm just going to take a little
aside here within the seed ad because
they suggest we talk about sleep and so
we're not going totally Off Script here
we have had the last two nights and we
have one more night coming County Wide
planned power outages in the San Juan
Islands and from 10 pm to 6 a.m ish
although the power comes out a little
bit earlier than that
and it is amazing
how even even for people who work on
keeping lights and noise and electronics
out of their immediate sleep environment
how it feels different when there is no
buzz there is no hum there is no
background anything going on and you
know this again from people who you know
we don't have I don't have my phone in
the room we don't have Electronics we
don't have any lights you know it's it's
it's dark and quiet and still
you know the electrons are racing
through the walls when the power is on
and it has been remarkable the last
couple nights yeah I noticed this
um whenever I travel
um because you and I are ruthless about
this stuff and we do a very good job and
the difference between that and what is
considered normal you know in a hotel
room is the number of like LED lights
every time we travel like ah we have to
travel with some electrical tape but
just like cover the lights right yeah
and it's it's uh it's nuts
um and then you're right the extra step
of when you know when the county uh
takes over and denies everybody
electrons at once it's amazing that uh
you know
Nature's still out there and uh it's
it's really the way you're supposed to
sleep yeah and it's I mean the we're
coming up on a full moon here so it's
not all that dark out unless you're
under trees
so uh
uh in you know in the dead of night uh
in an archipelago where the power has
been cut intentionally uh with a you
know few days shut of a full moon uh you
can still see you can still walk around
and see and and it's remarkable okay
back to the ad
ah
prioritizing regular sleep can thus help
keep your gut immune axis healthy you
can also support your gut immune access
by taking seeds ds01 daily synbiotic
seed is a plant-based Prebiotic and
probiotic with 24 strains that have been
clinically or scientifically studied for
their benefits 16 of those 24 strains
are specifically geared towards
digestive health and four of the 24
probiotic strands are known to promote
healthy skin your skin like your gut has
its own microbiome seed supports both
gut and skin health
seed is free from 14 major classes of
allergens including but not limited to
sugar animal products soy gluten peanut
glyphosate Dairy shellfish and corn
and seed is basically double hauled with
its capsule in capsule design it is
engineered to maintain
viability through your digestive tract
until it reaches your colon where you
want it and the same design makes it
resistant to oxygen moisture and heat
meaning that no Refrigeration is
necessary also meaning that you can
travel with it without it going
um
going rogue on you
seeds daily symbiotic supports gut skin
and heart health and micronutrient
synthesis we have heard from several
people who have used seed and Report
improvements in their just to function
in 24 to 48 hours so start a new healthy
habit today visit seed.com Dark Horse
and use code Darkhorse to redeem 25 off
your first month of seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic that seed.com Darkhorse or use
code Darkhorse at checkout spectacular
all right I blame the cough syrup do you
yes I do
is making this broadcast possible so I'm
I'm loathe to give it a hard time but
yeah I think that was the cough syrup
talking spectacular yeah I mean I think
it is a spectacular product but it's
just it's it is a spectacular generic
description for one and three were
generic
I know but given where I've been yeah
you know I feel like I feel I'm
succeeding at the exercise yeah okay
um
shall I start or should you start uh I
think you should start okay I will start
uh
I saw so I think I'm Gonna Save a number
of things for for Saturday
um but I was thinking about
talking about how
ridiculous
the mainstream media has become and
maybe this is part of where you're gonna
go but I have some examples here from
magazines that I subscribe to that come
into our house and that that are just
just have lost the plot if the plot is
in fact about journalism right
and then into the middle of that comes
uh nature the you know one of the two
premier scientific journals uh adoring
absurd interview with Peter Hotes about
his new book and uh the trials he's been
through all right which maybe we talk
about a little bit
but into that mix
I find a paper
published in the Open Access nature
publication so you know this is this is
pretty new this is within a few decades
that we had like these two big uh
Flagship journals and now they've got a
ton of journals underneath them that is
it's a nature Journal but the journal in
particular that I'm referring to here is
called scientific reports they've
metastasized
to size yes so the research that I came
across is remarkable and I thought cool
I want to just talk about some a result
like a scientific question that's out
there and a result and it's published in
this nature
property called scientific reports and
it's awesome and it sent me down a few
other roads and uh
I don't know maybe there's still hope
for science
maybe I'm not talking about the journal
okay like we need for there to be hope
for science there is easy hope for
science nothing but hope for science
there is less no hope for the the
academic thing that has been captured
that pretends to be synonymous with
science yeah
yeah so with that um intro it's about
cows which does not sound all that all
that interesting I imagine
um
but this this article that's been
published uh changes our understanding
of when and where cattle came from in
the new world and what that might mean
about the nature of cowboys as well
so the new world that's the Americas
North and South America
um have no native cattle
right the bovines uh and you know
everyone I think knows that a cow is a
bovine the bovines are a larger group
that includes water buffalo some of the
things we call Antelope although
Antelope is a polypholetic group
Antelope isn't isn't uh isn't a isn't a
good phylogenetic term one minor
correction I think you mean bovids nope
I mean Bo Vines all right um I stand
corrected uh you know I went I went down
this little rabbit war in a little bit
and I do not mean lagomorphs
um
uh yeah I had bovids written down and
then I went in I was like okay
apparently it's both Vines I don't care
right okay um but it's bovine's larger
group that include water buffalo
um and you know I I actually
I I think that there's still
disagreement in the literature around
this so I'm I I don't think we should
spend time there but so this larger
group that includes water buffalo some
of the things we call Antelope although
Antelope isn't a good group and um the
Pronghorn in the new world is not a true
Antelope and so it's not uh that's
that's actually a different kind of
organism and then bison so bison are new
world and bison of course were
incredibly abundant in the new world at
the point that uh
at the point well presumably that the
first people showed up uh whenever
exactly that was fifteen thousand thirty
thousand something years ago right a
long time ago uh and still
extraordinarily abundant at the point
that the Europeans showed up uh several
hundred years ago uh but they're quite
distinct like bison and cattle uh which
um the domesticated forms uh that got
domesticated at least twice distinctly
in the old world and got brought over to
the new world are quite distinct from
Buffalo and in fact
um not just phylogenically distinct but
physiologically and ecologically
distinct enough that you can't really
um you can't just assume that cattle
will do well any place that bison did do
well and in fact bison don't do well
some places that cattle can go in and
um and if they're allowed to just run
wild we'll do damage so you know we have
these fights these modern fights around
um public lands and grazing and such and
some of the arguments been like well
bison like well you know bison and
cattle haven't done the same things they
haven't been able to to go the same
places and they don't have the same
effects on ecosystems question for you
um do what you may not know the answer
bison is a wild animal yeah cattle are
derived from some wild animal and I
admit that at this moment I'm struggling
to remember what its uh wild uh
progenitor was it's uh it's I think it's
possible orox maybe and I'm probably
mispronouncing that word uh
in this paper somewhere
um
yeah actually I was going to read this
so I'll just I'll just read this little
piece from this paper right now before I
continue with my little story that I was
going to do so you can show this if you
like so this is actually Zach
um
so you can show it if you like this is
in this paper scientific reports which
is actually an Open Access Journal which
is nice it's a nature property if it's
open access ancient DNA confirms diverse
origins of early post-columbian cattle
in the Americas
and I was not ready to go here yet so
I'm going to go back to the story I was
going to go to but since you asked the
question file a geographic background of
cattle in the Americas let me make that
a little bit bigger for those
um
that did not work I have to make it
smaller again to fit it all on the
screen file a geographic background of
cattle in the Americas the Philo
geographic history of post-columbian
cattle can be described along two main
branches the maternal lineages defined
by mutations to the mitochondrial genome
and the paternal lineages described by
divergences and part of the Y chromosome
modern cattle emerge out of two separate
domestication events aurochs boss
primogeneous were first domestic so I
conflated those two so the common name
is orox I think is how you pronounce
that a-u-r-o-c-h-s scientific name being
boss primogenius were first domesticated
in Southwest Asia around 10 500 years
before present giving rise to the
taurine lineages boss Taurus about 8 000
years before present South Asian wild
cattle were then domesticated and gave
rise to boss indicus the zebu or
InDesign domestic cattle got it so one
of the interesting is a humped right for
we what we always saw in Madagascar were
zebu so you know just further
a total tangent here but Madagascar just
off the coast giant Island fourth
largest island in the world just off the
east coast of Africa is not African uh
you know it's originally part of
gondwana uh which which split and
separated into South America Africa
Madagascar India Australia
Antarctica but Africa actually split
away earlier such that Madagascar is
much more closely aligned evolutionarily
and geologically even with India and
Australia and South America even and
presumably if we could do ice cores in
Antarctica we'd find stuff there too but
anyway the cattle that you have in
Madagascar are in fact these newer
more recently domesticated zebu rather
than the ones with which we are mostly
familiar in the in the new world can I
get my screen back so I can think
um so
um
so bisoner new world but are not cattle
we've got two different domestication
events in the old world and uh bison as
I was saying before you asked your
question are really distinct both
phylogenetically but also
physiologically and ecologically and
they were never domesticated so they
were obviously hunted there were a lot
of uh ways that the local people across
the range of bison in the new world were
hunting bison but they were not
domesticated the way that boss Taurus
and boss was at indicus became
domesticated so I I want to take a
little detour here
um the book Guns Germs and Steel is very
much worth your time and if you don't
have time to read it it is very much
worth looking at the much uh Slimmer
three volume uh three-hour documentary
that was made of the book it will give
you the gist but one of the really deep
points in Guns Germs and Steel
is that it is not a haphazard assortment
of creatures that just happen to be
domesticated where people thought hey it
would be cool to have one of those where
I knew where to find it when I wanted to
eat it this is not the way this works at
all and the argument is made in a very
compelling Way by diamond in guns terms
of Steel but the point is when we say
that
um that bison were not domesticated what
we are really saying is they are not
domesticable because undoubtedly it was
attempted and the point is the
characteristics that are required
because it's not that the new world
peoples didn't domesticate animals right
they did not not very many and um but um
and in fact there's only one large
mammal that was successfully
domesticated in the new world and it was
uh vicuna or it was it was one of the
camellas I'm gonna I'm gonna guess yeah
but in any case the point is one of the
really powerful arguments in that book
is that the different wealth of
different populations on the world came
down to to historical accident that the
the number of creatures that were useful
and domesticable that were concentrated
in East Asia was high and those animals
could be moved east to west because
climatologically things didn't change
radically as you moved across Eurasia
and that actually tells the story about
why certain human groups devastated
other human groups the luck of having
domesticable creatures in your
environment was huge it was not the only
piece of luck but it was one of the
major ones so there's one one thing
buried in what you said that is
absolutely true but may not be obvious
to people but it's critical to the the
hypothesis to Diamond's hypothesis and
to the understanding of
um how things have tracked across the
world
um which is what you said was as you
move east to west things don't
inherently change climatologically as
much as they do as you move north to
south that is as you change latitude As
you move from the equator to the poles
you inherently go into
um more highly seasonal with regard to
temperature regime changes and more
extreme climates and whereas As you move
east to west you can certainly
experience great climatological change
and coastal regions from Inland regions
lowland regions from Upland regions are
going to be predictably different from
one another but especially if you have
not particularly changed your distance
from a Coast or your diff or your
distance above sea level your altitude
moving east to west doesn't inherently
change much and so you should be able to
take something from one space and move
it you know hundreds even thousands of
miles to the left to the right on the
globe effectively east or west but if
you try to do that North or South you're
likely to run to Trump right but anyway
so uh you know
uh bison R what they are from the point
of view of the big packet of nutrients
uh that are available to anybody and
they look similar they're closely
they're related but they're just not
identical but actually the key the key
example to the distinction is zebra
right a zebra is a striped horse never
domesticated not domesticated because
its temperament makes it impossible to
domesticate because the environment it
lives in is so perilous that what you
have is an extremely jittery animal
right
um and that extremely glittery animal
can't be domesticated so the point is
those of us who want pet zebras are
reduced to turning them into ceramic and
putting them on our desks we have to we
have to go with the second best ceramic
zebra strategy
um but this is a really important point
because you know of course a zebra would
be just as useful as a horse if you
could get it to behave in the ways that
horses do and fancier
yeah I mean better all around but
careful antagonize the horse contingent
here I know well I used to I used to
give Dick Alexander a hard time about uh
this because he was a horse fanatic and
I kept telling him that if he really
wanted to do the job writing needed
zebras which never failed to produce
annoyance on his part
but anyways uh the domestic ability of
creatures is the key question and
um
it didn't happen here for the various
reasons that uh put them off the list
indeed all right so uh bison in the new
world were never domesticated and the uh
the
stem cattle from which our modern
domesticated cattle were domesticated
came from the old world
so when Columbus arrived in the New
World in 1493 he brought with him cattle
from Spain they had apparently actually
come off the Canary Islands which is 50
miles or so off the west coast of Africa
but those we think we think historians
and others who think about this
professionally think had come from a
Spanish cattle
and he thus introduced what become this
major transformational species in the
new world because cattle of course have
become culturally economically just a
huge piece of of what it is to be in the
new world and this is true now but it
was in some ways even more prominent uh
in the early days of the Spanish
Colonial
activities here
okay so
um
it has been assumed therefore for a long
time that the vast majority of New World
cattle come from Europe which then tells
one kind of story about how those cattle
were used and who was managing them but
this new work that was published this
week strongly suggests that cattle were
brought from Africa far earlier than had
been imagined so let me say I've now
I said okay there were two different
domestication events uh what was it like
10 500 years ago uh and 8 000 years ago
or so but the Western the older
domestication event which which produced
um basically the cattle that we are
familiar with uh mostly and uh and the
cattle in Europe and Africa are all from
that first domestication event however
they've been domesticated for so long
and they exist across this great
latitudinal gradient from northern
Europe all the way into Africa that they
too have begun to diversify and so we
can tell with some Modern genetic tools
along two different lines of evidence uh
that uh something about where these
cattle may have been coming from so the
two different lines of evidence as was
implied but not well spelled out in that
little paragraph that I read before are
matroline which is they can look at
mitochondrial DNA and they're also
looking at petroline which is changes in
the evolution of the Y chromosome okay
but I missed something yeah
I thought I heard you say that cattle
were
um
introduced more than once and introduced
to where to the new world
well this is what this news okay go on
but here's the question the cattle that
would have been in Africa
would not have been zebu no they weren't
right so where in that were these
Southern African cattle were they
brought in no no it's it's West it's
West Africa and this is part of I don't
want to I don't want to give away the
okay the punch finder uh but the the
potentially confusing thing here is that
uh these these cattle that we did know
that uh historians I don't know if it's
archaeologists uh that people who have
been thinking about cattle in the new
world and cattle throughout the old
world and also the people who were
working with them and what it meant to
be a cowboy in the new world didn't know
it has been widely accepted and I think
this is not changing this part of the
story is not changing the first cattle
brought into the new world were brought
by Columbus in 1493.
okay
um but it has been a thought that uh
there while there is evidence and that
was basically a European cattle and it's
been thought that while there were some
African cattle that were brought in uh
that have mixed with the European cattle
both of which are not the zebu this is
all boss Taurus okay that that happened
a couple hundred years later
and basically at that point the
Spaniards had everything figured out and
they were brought in because they were
better because basically West Africa had
some similarity ecologically uh to some
of for instance like the pompous in
Argentina uh whereas the cattle coming
out of Europe weren't doing as well in
some of the Landscapes that people were
trying to introduce cattle into in the
New World
and the story has been
that the Spaniards had all the
cattlemanship that they needed and that
they were sometimes employing enslaved
populations to
to work with the cattle to handle the
cattle but this was basically just
unskilled labor that this was brute
forced labor and they had nothing to do
with the actual working of the cattle
and so you can maybe begin to see them I
am I'm jumping forward here a little bit
what what it might mean to discover that
actually African cattle truly African
cattle had been introduced in the new
world earlier than we had thought
so what this new research finds by
looking at in two different kinds of
genetic evidence again through through
the mother the matter line through
mitochondrial DNA which is only
transferred um through the through the
matriline and patraline level evidence
through uh changes in uh basically the Y
chromosome
um and they've beguns they've This
research they've sourced Bones from
museums all over the new world and of
course archaeological digs all the time
uh looking at that also
what they find is basically out of step
with with the historical records have
said about when African cattle start to
be brought over now historical records
are largely going to have been recorded
at the time by religious authorities
from Spain who had an interest in in
telling a story that that befitted them
and
let's see this so This paragraph that I
already read to you guys
um
sort of Recaps what I've said so far
about two different kinds of evidence
and uh and where the cattle are coming
from
the new work says
yes
we think it's right first Kettle in the
new world late 1400s from uh you know
picked up in the Canary Islands but
basically from Europe from from Spain
but also
far earlier than we had first thought in
the early 1600s basically a hundred
years after the first introduction of
cattle into the new world we have cattle
coming in from Africa
and let me find this paragraph here uh
the last
paragraph of the discussion I believe if
I can
get my computer to show what I needed to
show
um sorry guys
internal lineages here we go
okay so my computer is not doing what I
wanted to do I just want to show
this paragraph
here we go okay now you can show it this
is
final paragraph of the discussion
African origins question mark
the question of the potential African
origin of some Colonial cattle is of
immense historical significance and has
deep social and cultural ramifications
particularly when considering the
central role played by African workers
and setting up the ranching industry in
the colonial Americas
our archaeological genetic evidence of
cattle parallels these documented
aspects of the early Spanish Empire in
the Americas the organization of the
colonial labor system the timing of the
African slave trade and the high
specialization of enslaved workers in
cattle management
while the European colonists held most
of the economic and political power they
relied on a diverse Workforce mainly
compiles comprised mainly composed of
native and African coerced workers to
generate their wealth in both urban and
rural regions from Mexico to Peru
in rural areas the knowledge of these
laborers and their adaptability to the
tropical conditions of some parts of
Spanish America were also particularly
valued
workers of African descent were
particularly prominent in one craft in
particular cattle ranching numerous
historical sources suggest that this
enslaved Workforce played a crucial role
in the management of the numerous herds
of cattle that roamed semi-freely in
different regions of the Americas
Caribbean Gulf Coast of Mexico Oaxaca
South America and yanos overall it seems
that complex transcolonial
collaborations opened a potential
conduit for a wide array of products
including cattle alongside alongside
enslaved Africans in the Caribbean and
Mesoamerican regions after the 1550s
our data while not fully conclusive
further supports the hypothesis that
cattle were also imported from Africa to
the Americas highlighting the central
role of African herders in the emergence
of the new agricultural landscape mainly
based on cattle ranching
there's a lot there and uh one one thing
to sort of untangle there is
there seems to have been and this this
has been long understood by people who
are tracking the slave trade the African
slave trade into into the new world uh a
focus in part on um on pulling people on
stealing people from their homelands and
moving them to a totally new place
um who were themselves skilled ranchers
who were themselves active domesticators
of and herders of cattle
and with this with these new and you
know the data are a little dicey and I'm
not going into it like the patreon data
only they had eight uh I think eight
samples only three of them yielded
anything so you know there's it's it's
not beautiful you know beautifully clear
data and it's you were you require a lot
of inference to to figure these things
out but if they're right if they're
right that Africa were actually brought
in only a hundred years or so
about after the first
cattle were introduced to the new world
and that is also a very tight fit for
when the slave trade started to pick up
then probably what was happening was
that the cattle and the people were
brought in simultaneously and the people
were brought in in part because they
already had expertise with these cattle
and this begins to change a really
important part of a story around uh you
know the European peopling of of the new
world where this image that we have of
you know John Wayne style Cowboys on on
a horse in the American West while true
was not the first time that we had
Cowboys in in the new world and in fact
what it seems like is that very likely
African and African-American uh peoples
were in fact the first cowboys in the
new world and all right so this uh the
whole time that you were setting this up
there was the elephant shrew in the room
for me which is what we memologists say
instead of the elephant in the room
never said that before no nor has any
other
um mammologist but um or even do
elephants it is the kind of thing that
even in that company would elicit an eye
roll if I said something like that which
would make me feel strangely good but
um anyway
the thing that was not adding up to me
at all yeah was the calculus that would
cause people to actually import
members of a species that was already
present on the target end of the journey
the difficulty of transporting
especially you know live creatures that
consume vast amounts of resource uh the
advantage you know you the way you set
it up it sounded like well
these animals were from a place that
might make them better prepared uh you
know the language we would obviously use
as they'd be better adapted to the
habitats
um where they might be ending up
but that requires that people understand
some analog of better adapted and this
would obviously be very early for such
an understanding although there was
clearly an understanding of the kinds of
selection that one has to go through uh
in order to shape creatures uh under
domestication but
it did occur to me in fact it was the
hypothesis that I was going to float was
that what they were really importing was
a
useful pair people who knew the animals
and animals
that responded in a productive way
but that requires I mean this this
really tells a very different story
right that it would be worth paying the
huge costs of importing redundant
creatures
um because of the much better yield that
one would get from uh people who were
already uh you're calling them Cowboys
but somehow already expert in managing
these particular individuals
and presumably that means
the exact living individual that was
transported
presumably it is not that the the people
in question were better at managing
creatures with genetics like the the
cows that they had been managing right
although there was probably some there
was cultural understanding of how to be
a cattle herder among the populations of
people who were stolen and enslaved and
moved across the Atlanta of course right
but the point is if what you were really
getting was the expertise which no doubt
they did you don't need to import the
animals the point is that animal is like
the one that you've been dealing with
deal with it the same way
and
um this is a Step Beyond that the idea
that there might be enough value in
getting people who were expert at these
particular animals who then might have
an impact on their own offspring in
other words you have uh in mammals this
capacity to pass inherent in information
both in the genome and outside of it and
so
the um the cow that gives birth to a
calf the cow has an interaction with the
person who's managing it and passes on
some of the
um the information about how to be
managed uh to her Offspring passively
right so it's still hard for me to
imagine that that overcomes the huge
cost of importing
these animals
but well it does demand some sort of an
explanation there were apparently
several uh
importation events that sounds like the
wrong word importation but there were
there were there were the historical
record shows several instances of moving
cows over in part because uh the you
know the initial the initial import was
a tiny amount of tiny tiny number of
cows well and that has that has a couple
of downsides one which the original the
original you know you create a huge
bottleneck that has
um powerful implications over you know
you have basically a not very diverse uh
Offspring population no matter how big
it is which means it's a slow to adapt B
more vulnerable to things like disease
but of course the people in question
wouldn't really understand that they
might have some sort of intuitive sense
but they will they presumably will have
been experiencing oh my God our cattle
aren't doing very well we need to bring
in more uh somehow you know these after
I'm gonna make up numbers here you have
to ten generations of breeding these 10
cattle together these original 10 cattle
together uh they're getting less and
less fecund uh they're getting more and
more susceptible to disease maybe we
need some new blood and you know that's
a phrase that has been used yeah and
it's actually you know no one had to
know what that actually meant you know
you wanted to know about inbreeding
depression in order to say we need some
new blood and that's going to help solve
this problem right and undoubtedly
um skilled breeders would have some sort
of language for this that line is too
too narrow it's too close yeah much but
I don't think we were really talking
about skilled breeders in the 1500s in
the new world we're talking about you
know Spanish Colonial I'm talking on the
other end
that you would have people who had
experience successfully you know they
wouldn't necessarily know what they knew
yeah right they would those you're
talking about Africa now or you're
talking about having a small African
populations of both cattle and people
having been brought over I'm talking
about the people who made the decision
to put cattle on a ships who are
presumably not Africans
um that in farming circles people had
useful knowledge encoded in ways that
was only partly literal right there are
instincts about you shouldn't do that
and you may not know exactly why it
doesn't work but
so the point is still you have to get to
this you know in chemistry we'd call it
the activation energy
point at which you know that you it's
not just a good idea to bring in some uh
new cattle to your uh deceptively uh I
guess it would be a deceptively large
population it's a effectively small
population because it was sourced from a
tiny set of progenitors but it looks
like a large population
to get to the point that you're actually
importing new animals when you could get
animals where you're going it has to
overcome that huge burden well I mean I
think so you've made an assumption that
by the time uh African cattle were being
brought over along with African people
being brought over that there was
already a large population of cattle in
the new world and I don't know that that
is true well they're also and I also
suspect that by then because there had
been not that many individuals who had
originally been brought over from the
European uh breeds that those cattle
that were in the new world were probably
not doing as well as they might have
been not doing as well as they might
have been so this suggests the other
potential hypotheses one you know to us
looking down on a map of the new world
it sort of seems like well there were
cattle here but you know if the cattle
are 500 miles away from where you intend
to set up cattle ranches the difficulty
of getting them there while smaller over
land is not necessarily small and so you
could imagine somebody making such a
decision because they were trying to
land some cattle somewhere that they
weren't totally
um yeah so uh couple more things here
there's a piece of work from 2015 by a
guy named sluter apologies if I'm
butchering his name
published in a journal called
environment and history called how
Africans and their descendants
participate in establishing open range
cattle ranching in the Americas
and I have just a little paragraph to
read from the paper it's a very
interesting paper overall before I read
this paragraph let me say there's a word
in it uh
I believe uh is a pike pole tipped with
a crescent Hawking knife uh and it has
been used to capture feral cattle and
then been outlawed by the local Spanish
authorities but enforcement of the law
outlawing it was racially biased so the
Das horatadera was the way that feral
cattle were chased down and they
supposedly cut off at the at the
Achilles and then and then you know
pieces taken for whatever Parts they
wanted and then sort of Left for their
corpses to be uh to be taken by wild
animals was very wasteful it was quite
barbaric and at a point that there was
beginning to be
food problems in various places the
Spanish authorities were like no more
you can't use that thing but they
basically always uh always punished
dark-skinned people when they found them
with it and rarely punished
white-skinned people so that's just a
little bit of background here setting up
this conclusion this very long paper
um
in which uh he argues having laid out
all the evidence previously Africans and
afro-descendants in the Americas had
antecedent knowledge of Saddle horns
lassos and open range cattle herding
already knew about these things
they had already invented them
had a substantial presence on ranches in
New Spain sometimes his major domos and
owners of the consequent latitude to
innovate
Ann had a strong motivation for
inventing and refining a non-lethal
alternative to the desaratadera to avoid
the racially based sanctions of the
mesta ordinances of the late 16th
century
so that's just a tight summary of a
number of pieces of evidence that I'm
not going to go through here and this
this piece published eight years ago in
which before there was any evidence
there were actually African cattle maybe
already being brought over like you know
what actually the story about yes we're
going to use slave labor to do our Brute
Force work but they don't know anything
do they and we're going to let the
Spaniards do all the thinking there was
already this sort of archival and
material evidence evidence uh around
actually it seems like the Africans and
the African-Americans
had a lot of knowledge that they would
have used that they actually seem to
have innovated both herding cattle on
Horseback and lassos
that those those were Innovations from
from Africans rather than from Spaniards
which is amazing well you know this is
the
we have this way that we think about
slavery that is itself so deeply racist
right yeah totally the point about human
slaves and the point every time it's
happened it's not like slavery was
invented you know for for the new world
slavery is a
a very common pattern in human history
the point is a human being is smart can
innovate can do things can take
instructions and can figure out how to
apply them in some situation that they
weren't instructed over to recognize
patterns recognize problems to solve the
problems by using the patterns they have
observed right it's the ultimate beast
of burden because it's smart and so the
portrayal that this is about you know
stupid brutes no that's what the you
know animals
that's what the animals were right
sources of force right right the people
were sources of innovation inside the
ability to problem solve and all of that
and we paper over that and it's it's a
very it's a very foolish uh
misunderstanding because you you do miss
things like that yeah you're surprised
that of course you know you know any
person set to do any difficult job
figures out how to do it in ways that
waste less of their time that put them
in less danger right this is this is the
natural orientation of the human mind
exactly
so um Slaughter the art of the author of
the article from 2015 is quoted uh the
reason the way I found his work is that
he's quoted in a science news article
about this research that we've been
talking about
which is indeed how I first got here
because the science news article
is garbage
it's garbage and here's here's what it
looks like
this is again science in its News
section reporting on this article in a
nature publication that we've been
talking about which finds that uh cows
the cattle were brought over into the
new world from Africa far earlier than
we had thought and what the implications
for that are
America's first cowboys were enslaved
Africans ancient cow DNA suggests
cattle may have been imported from
Africa centuries earlier than historians
thought
okay so far so okay
think cowboy and you might picture John
Wayne riding hurt across the U.S West
but the first cowboys lived in Mexico
and the Caribbean and most of them were
black that's the conclusion of a recent
analysis of DNA from 400 year old cow
bones excavated on the island of
Hispaniola and its sites in Mexico the
work published in scientific reports
also provides evidence that African
cattle made it to the Americas at least
a century earlier than historians
realized
so
that may sound like just a kind of
slightly bungled and kind of big report
on the research that I've just told you
guys about
but no
the conclusion of the research the
research was
African cattle made it to the Americas
at least a century earlier than
historians realized again not conclusive
but pretty strong evidence that that is
the the actual conclusion
the conclusion that
therefore what was going on was uh
Africans and African cattle being
imported at the same time and uh
earliest Cowboys in the new world being
African that is an inference derived
from the research they have reversed the
science news
science news article has reversed the
actual research and claimed that what
they were doing was one thing and then
yes you can also see this this other
thing about cows and I get it cows art
is sexy as racism and cowboys but
[__] sake like this this is
this is why we can't have good science
yeah that's it right there it is and you
know it's an analog of uh my principle
which
goes the degree to which you can trust
science goes down as you get in close
proximity to money yeah right the degree
to which a result is likely to be true
in astrophysics if we're talking about
you know remote galaxies where there's
no uh money at stake you know I'm not
saying it's true or it's false but the
chances that it's right are much much
higher than if you get anywhere near
medicine for example where there's so
much money at stake that science is just
completely overwhelmed and in this case
the problem is that
the esging of the world has meant that
now anything that has these
characteristics in play anything that
impinges on narratives of exploitation
racism slavery Etc is so charged that it
would be almost impossible just to
Simply get an uninflected analytical
read on the evidence because how would
that even happen right how would that
even happen
so that's that's most of what I wanted
to say here I did want to find just one
mostly I did not
independently assess the the methods
some of them you and I are familiar with
some of them were not you know a lot has
changed since we were learning about
molecular systematics in grad school
um
you know they're using maximum
likelihood approaches but they're also
you know it's a mixture and there's a
lot of things there that um
that have room for uh potential
potential confusion in the data overall
I was impressed with what seemed to be a
very careful approach but one thing I
would love to find this
I'm just not able to find
um
apologies
I'm not able to find the the bit on
their methods
which
and when I wanted to quote it to you
guys directly but
um they're talking about having done
something in which uh they've outsourced
the analysis because one often does with
lab techniques and they chose to do X
rather than y analysis because that's
what the vendor effectively the vendor
who is doing the analysis and who is
going to return their results to them
has recommended
and
I've read that and I thought okay maybe
that's the right decision I don't know
we're outside of my field of expertise
here I don't do this kind of analysis I
never did
but it feels and again like I think that
this research was really well done I'm
very impressed with it this is not at
all an attack on This research but uh
it's now become de regrets it's expected
like you can't if you're doing
complicated research with a lot of
different kinds of techniques like you
you are going to Outsource some amount
of the of the data analysis
it's unnerving and I think dangerous
honestly
um how much of high-tech science is done
based on recommendations from vendors
from so hold on from vendors and what we
don't have is okay so those vendors
exist and they've come up with
recommendations and they're based on
something but they're not publishing
science
um that explains why their
recommendations are what they are that
we can assess like everything about that
recommendation from that vendor is
cryptic to us and maybe even to the
authors of the paper so a lot of the
analysis here a lot of these results
depends on correct assumptions and
decisions on the part of third-party
Labs whose work we can't see and so this
is just you know again this is like a
side note that's critically important
and not specific to this work although
it was prompted by seeing just a note in
their in their materials and methods
section
um I think you're not being nearly harsh
enough on what you've found there
um because in effect saying based on a
vendor recommendation the vendor's
recommendation was presumably based on
something
the fact that I finally found it this
kit uses a uracil tolerant polymerase
and performs well with degraded and low
yield samples this method was
recommended by the vendor as being
particularly efficient in converting
short single-stranded fragments of
uracil containing DNA into NGS libraries
well particularly efficient so maybe
efficient just means you don't have to
spend as much and we can get there
faster
but yeah I mean if it's just if it's
just a technical question if the point
is this is going to work and yield
um evidence in a way that does not
change what the evidence is then fine I
don't even think recommendation from the
vendor belongs there though because what
that suggests is I cannot tell you why
the vendor recommended this if you can
tell it then the fact that the
recommendation came from the vendor is
immaterial exactly the point is the
answer is either this method is more
efficient or it isn't vendor is beside
the point that that's what citations is
for right like that this this is this is
one of the things that I was always
extremely fussy it seems to some of my
students about very finicky about like
you attribute
to your Source absolutely anything that
is not common knowledge and which you
are not fully explaining and even if
you're fully explaining it if it's
someone else's idea you attribute it but
in this case the fact that it's
recommended by the vendor is here as the
standard like that's the attribution
right instead of actually we need to
know why
right and so this and
the attribution isn't complete because
when you cite you're saying okay you can
go look at this paper to see on what
basis I made that decision and you
should be able to follow it all the way
back to the original why like why did
you do it that way that's that's what
the scientific record that's what the
you know that's what the Publications
are about and in this case recommended
by the vendor on what basis where's this
where's the publication like was there
science done or is this or was this a
financial decision on the part of the
vendor like we we just don't know and
again I'm not saying there's necessarily
anything bad that happened here but it
did that was one of the few red flags
that popped up for me as I was reading
this paper like oh
damn like this is the way of modern
science so much of modern science yeah I
agree and it's a shame to uh to explore
this on a paper that sounds like it was
basically well done yeah but what it
speaks to is that there's a culture in
which nobody blinks if you say oh um
yeah no in your method section yes this
was done because of the recommendation
of the vendor and it's like the
recommendation of the vendor is based on
something that's what needs to be in
your paper right
foreign
all right
um
can I just share a tiny bit about hotels
uh sure yeah I mean he's pretty great
the amazing hotels the amazing Peter
Hotes
so
a nature property published this is
pretty great paper with a lot of
interesting implications all right no no
please don't show my screen
um with a lot of amazing implications
about
um about origin of uh you know cattle in
the new world and cowboys in the new
world and the African slave trade and
all of this and
nature also
this week so This research we've been
talking about was published actually in
August in science news just made its um
stupid summary of it this week is why I
came across it recently but here we have
nature this week vaccine specialist
Peter Hotes scientists are under attack
for someone else's political gain
you don't say
I don't think he's talking about us no
um you know the funny thing is
um he's right he's right scientists are
under attack for someone else's
political game Peter Hotes is political
gain and he's the one doing the
attacking in many cases yeah yeah it's a
it's an amazing thing to say yeah the
physician researcher who spoke out
against misinformation during the
covid-19 pandemic says attacks against
science are formidable and getting worse
yeah we noticed
okay so I mean this is ridiculous this
whole thing's ridiculous it's a book
review because how Tes has a book out oh
yeah um and um The Deadly rise of
anti-science a scientists warning
um published by Johns Hopkins University
press Johns Hopkins has been terrific
during all of this as well I just want
to scan to the bottom of this ridiculous
thing and um share the last paragraph
Okay
um here we go here we go okay how can
this be stopped what's your advice for
dealing with online trolls have you
changed anyone's mind
and your book's dedication you thank
police departments and hospital security
forces for keeping your family safe how
do you deal with fear
the end of that answer he says they with
regard to the right wing media stoking
fear and outrage no stoking the faux
outrage machine
monetizing the internet they couldn't
care less about me it's what I represent
he says ooh shades of fouches shades of
vouchers okay so what's your message to
scientists nature asks hotels in its
final adoring question to him
understand hota says that Science And
scientists are under threat and it's a
coordinated campaign what you're doing
as a scientist is Noble scientists
should feel good about what they do by
reading my book you shouldn't be
demoralized understand that it's not you
who's doing something wrong you're under
attack for someone else's political gain
even though it's scary I think there's
some comfort in that
yeah that takes something from a guy
who's still uh pushing mRNA vaccines for
kids yeah the ball's on this guy yeah
um amazing uh tiny but a very effective
apparently yeah I guess in this case
maybe the gall is a better like imagine
imagine him covering Galls or something
I will hold my tongue about all the
things that one might say connecting
Galls for those of you playing along at
home are the swellings on Plants induced
by insects we then lay their eggs inside
these um they're not attractive and the
plants presumably don't like them
they're not good for the plants no it's
not good for the plants yeah pretty cool
though I was uh very interesting I've
always always I'm intrigued when I
encounter them yeah
yeah so
um you know nature or the nature group
is still publishing really interesting
research and then also this
unintentionally accurate
but not in the way they uh they suspect
yes
hit piece on like itself and everything
it's doing accurate when understood
upside down right yeah yeah all right
all right
um I had a couple things I wanted to do
I don't think my voice is going to hold
out so I'm just going to do one of the
two and we'll come back to the other
I wanted to talk about two pieces of
news sciency news that emerged
um this week that I think people are
going to need a little bit of
translating to understand
once you do I think you'll realize that
things are afoot that we need to be
aware of the first one
came from Ralph Barrick who published a
paper
that once again brings back you would
remind us Ralph Ralph Barrick uh at uh
Chapel Hill is the
um
primary architect of the set of
techniques uh in gain of function
research used to Turbo Charge and
enhance especially
coronaviruses in other words though we
think much of the work that resulted in
coronavirus happened in Wuhan the
precursor work that uh created the
insight into how to modify
viruses to take them from a state in
which they were not an effective human
pathogen into a highly effective human
pathogen came from the Barrick lab he
famously innovated but
what he called no see him techniques
which meant that Not only was he able to
make modifications that made these
things into deadly pathogens
um but he was able to do so in a way
that was invisible to those who might
look in and see whether some
modification had been made
and uh the kind of research that he was
doing that he was doing primarily in the
U.S
uh I got a cease and desist order placed
on it under the Obama Administration and
then
fauci's niaid helped move much of that
research offshore to the Wuhan Institute
of virology yeah so I sort of think of
Barrack as the guy who made all this
possible and fouchy is the guy who made
it all happen
all right
um anyway Barrick has been
um
quite quiet when he pipes up it is
because something important is afoot and
so Zach if you would show
um the Barrick paper you can actually
tell me which one that is I don't see
him
wow don't know what to do about that
Zach um
nature microbiology paper
um if you want to forward me things I
can figure it out quickly
so I will talk about what is taking
place you please and I believe I emailed
you them as well
um the important piece of information
here Barrick is the last author on this
paper which is uh effectively the power
position
um
nope
and what happens here is the Revival
of a
hypothesis in a new form so weberic
hypothesizes
year
um
is is are you there yes he's on the
right
and if you'll scroll down actually if
you would search for the term
immunosuppressed
there it is okay
what happens here is that Barrick
attempts to revive the hypothesis that
many will remember from the very early
parts of the pandemic that the
intermediate host between horseshoe bats
and humans for SARS cov2 was pangolins
now this work is long discredited there
were coronaviruses found in pangolins
these were pangolins that were being
smuggled there's no ecological
explanation for why pangolins would be
harboring these bat viruses there are
many many reasons to Discount this
explanation but what Barrick attempts to
do here
is create an unfalsifiable explanation
of how this virus came to humans and
left no Trace
now as as our viewers will remember me
talking about can I just read what I'm
seeing here like this is brand new to me
um pangolins which harbor distinct Stars
Kobe 2 related strains are an endangered
solitary species but are valuable as
illegal trade commodities
on the basis of broad ace2 receptor
usage of pgcovgd documented Airborne
transmission potential and efficient
growth in primary nasal Airway Airway
epithelial cells we suggest that
individual pangolins or perhaps some
other rare Wildlife species was
productively infected and served as a
nearly untraceable pass-through species
that transmitted Virus to humans
[Music]
is he serious here yes and then he says
such rare events might be enhanced if
early human cases were immunosuppressed
potentially generating complex
mutational variants during persistent
infections so make no mistake what's
going on here
Barrack is creating a theoretically
possible pathway that would leave no
evidence if you started with the if you
said
Dr Barrick
the virus did not come from a lab
what is your best explanation of how it
might have gotten to us without leaving
any evidence of an intermediate host in
which it circulated or evidence in early
human populations where rapid Evolution
took place because it was poorly adapted
when it first made its way into people
if you said come up with your best
your best scenario that will accomplish
these things you would come up with
something like this doesn't make it
plausible but the point is what he is
hypothesizing here I think best could be
better than this nope you don't think so
you're not understanding the assignment
okay what's this I don't yeah I don't
the assignment is exonerate the lab with
an unfalsifiable hypothesis that could
have happened oh you know I mean like
scientifically best most plots this is
scientific garbage right you know this
is unfalsified it's like put a side lab
as a possibility now what's the most
supported hypothesis out there so the
base the basic
um reality
is that jumping between species is much
much harder than the people who have
been getting Grant after Grant on the
basis that it was always threatening to
happen have led us to believe and it
leaves a signature because you have to
have these periods of evolution in which
the virus gets better at uh infecting
people and then very importantly jumping
between them it has to do that so what
he's done
is he has cooked up a scenario in which
an immunosuppressed person becomes like
a little gain of function laboratory
unto themselves having gotten the virus
from a Pangolin
and the basic point is that's why we
haven't found any evidence right it's
it's a complete nonsense story designed
to exonerate the lab once again bringing
pangolins back in because as long as
we're now dealing with
unfalsifiable fantasy [__] might as
well be pangolins right might as well be
might as well be why not so anyway
another nature property instantly yeah
that's diabolical nonsense but the point
is this is now happening outside of your
view you weren't even supposed to notice
that I didn't know Barrick was Reviving
pangolins as a vector
all right that's one of the two pieces I
wanted to point to
the other piece is yeah
I did this this also
this garbage has no place in nature
it's not nature it's not science yeah
this is
um how do we get this is cover your ass
right this is this is Barrick covering
their asses because what they can't have
he's a thing now uh well he and all of
the people who might face a
um you know
criminal prosecution or who knows what
are looking
for a scientific cloak and Barrack uh is
not as good at generating
um seamless [__] when it comes to
narrative as he is creating seamless
[__] when it comes to genomes
okay
the other things I wanted to point out a
point to was I came across something I
happened to be looking at Merlin tuttles
um
Twitter profile he's not highly active
on Twitter but anyway Merlin Tuttle is
somebody I greatly admire he is uh a bad
conservationist he's an excellent
scientist and he is also I think
unarguably the greatest bat photographer
who has ever lived um he's quite a
lovely guy and I admire his photographic
work his scientific work and his
dedication to saving Batson
I will say that
um somehow you know
bats are the Jews of the Animal Kingdom
so they're blamed for all kinds of [__]
they're not responsible for
um so I couldn't see that guy well
so the reason I say that is because I
mean so so Merlin Tuttle responded to a
Scientific American piece
yeah so
um begin reading the Scientific American
piece okay a secret oh I'm on my screen
a secret weapon and preventing the next
pandemic fruit bets new research links
bad habitat distraction with a spillover
for their viruses to humans more than
four dozen Jamaican fruit bats destined
for a lab in Bozeman Montana are set to
become part of an experiment with an
ambitious goal predicting the next
Global pandemic bats worldwide are
primary Vector survives translation from
animals to humans those viruses often
are harmless to bats but can be deadly
to humans horseshoe bats in China for
example are cited as a likely cause of
the kova 19 outbreak all right that's
that's good that's good enough so the
point is this is uh nonsense the idea
that bats are a Scientific American has
become world-class purveyor of nonsense
of nonsense but anyway the idea that
bats are this uh primary reservoir for
human disease is wrong but it's a very
appealing notion because people have a
sort of creepy feeling about bats
and anyway Merlin Tuttle
uh wrote a piece in which he makes
actually many of the same points that I
made in my piece in unheard several
years ago when the pandemic first
happened and it was clear that a bat
virus had made it into people and I had
this oh my God moment I used to work
with bats I used to work with them with
my bare hands and was I risking
was I risking
um putting you know creating a pandemic
just by the simple fact of my work on as
it was tent making fruit bats
in that piece I concluded No in fact
this is nonsense
um a the line that we are always sold
about uh it is the pressure that human
populations are putting on shrinking
nature habitat that's putting humans in
contact with Wildlife Evermore this is
all nonsense this is designed to get
um grant money but anyway put all that
aside what's troubling here first of all
I know the particular bats the 48 bats
that are in route to this lab in the U.S
um I know this species very well what
what are we talking about now Jamaican
fruit bats the article that you were
reading from reports that somebody has
captured
four dozen uh Jamaican fruit bats and is
transporting them to a lab in the U.S
for an ambitious experiment now I would
say Jamaican is it artebius Jeremy
census artibias jamaic census it's the
most common animal to if you put up a
net looking for bats in the neotropics
this is the most likely animal that
you're gonna get it's a fairly large
animal it's very aggressive when you
handle it and in fact the key that helps
you recognize which bat you're holding
uh always says bites ferociously when
handled if it's a diagnostic it's so
great it's one of the great Diagnostics
what species do I have well the he drew
blood yeah bites ferociously but
um
anyway
here's what's troubling
this is a great story right you've got
scientists who have figured out because
bats are this reservoir of potential
human diseases and yet the bats tolerate
those diseases so well what we're going
to do is we're going to stop the next
pandemic by studying the interaction of
viruses with some bats right now the
problem is this is total horseshit
bats is a very big group we're talking
about something like a thousand
different species these fruit bats
couldn't be farther from those bats that
do actually Harbor some diseases we need
to worry about the Horseshoe bats yeah
so say that again or like a quarter of
all extant mammals are bats and there
are five thousand species of mammals
we're talking about well over a thousand
species So when you say like oh bats oh
God bats are bad like it's like saying
like I don't even know what it's like
saying I have no similar it's insane
there's so many different kinds of bats
out there and they eat all manner of
different things and therefore have all
manner of different risks in terms of
what they could give to humans right and
this one would not be high on my list
for
um species to be worried about in this
regard because for one thing it's a
dedicated fruit bat it doesn't live in
huge aggregations in general
um so you know there's a question about
yes this to somebody who's not paying
terribly much attention has money to
give for Grants this may sound like a
plausible story and why would we not
spend a little bit of money you know a
few hundred thousand dollars
to study the question of how bats
tolerate disease so well but not only is
this just basically a randomly chosen
bat probably chosen because it's
relatively easy to Source but it's not
going to yield them anything useful for
one thing the experiment that they have
apparently proposed they are going to
infect it with influenza
right influenza
is not is
you know as bad a choice as Rando bat is
for modeling those few bats that
actually Harbor something important to
people this is effectively
randovirus relative to the bat well it's
I mean from the beginning of this
pandemic and of course before that what
we see is category error after category
error oh I'm going to call it a bat okay
bats are bats it's a virus viruses
viruses this is a vaccine vaccines is
vaccines and we know we like vaccines
right it's the same trick over and over
and over again and sometimes it's just
ignorance but sometimes it's not right
and
the real tragedy here okay first of all
um we do this [__] all the time you know
I given the amount of tragedy that we
um create needlessly in the name of
science it's hard for me to get too
upset about you know
50 bats
but a this is a needless these bats a
they're all going to have to be
destroyed okay you're giving these bats
flu
these animals are going to need to be
destroyed you're doing it for no reason
and worse
and this is the punch line of this story
I bet you the people who are doing this
experiment do not even know that they
are involved in gain a function
they are involved in the piece of gain
of function that actually matters what
they are going to do is they are going
to forcibly jump a virus to a creature
right in order to see what happens when
that virus
infects that animal what they are doing
is they are creating an environment in
which that virus can evolve Now is it
going to evolve in some way that's going
to matter to people maybe probably not
but if it did you're talking about
influenza you are talking about giving
influenza a novel environment inside of
creatures that it wouldn't ordinarily be
in and if it did Escape what that means
is it's not a curiosity it's now again a
problem because you're talking about a
human pathogen so
I don't know what we do about this I
don't know how many dumb Grant
applications there are in the world like
this where somebody proposes something
that's actually dangerous for reasons
they may not even understand and the
people who are granting the funds are so
used to ignoring people who say that's
dangerous don't do it that the point is
you know they listen to that voice from
from hotels these are attacks on science
yeah you know science has to be done you
like science don't you do you really
want us not to know how it is that bats
endure viruses so well that is how we
are going to get away from the next
pandemic right we have to do this work
and the answer is the work is worthless
it's obvious from a cursory pass over
what they're doing that it's not going
to yield something useful right it's not
even likely to yield information but
what it is going to do is it's going to
take a small risk of releasing something
novel that infects people and you know
what will happen if that occurs
a massive [__] cover-up
right we are going to have another
cover-up where we are going to pretend
that this new uh influenza that we are
seeing that just so happens to have
emerged nearby the lab where where these
fruit bats were being injected that's a
coincidence right and somehow it's going
to be racist that we notice
you didn't have us read anything from
this Tuttle piece yeah I just
um I just scanned it and I looked at his
footnotes and there's something else
hidden here which I don't think you know
um so you can share my screen here this
is this is again Merlin Tuttle um
extraordinary um bat and he's a
biologist yeah absolutely and and
photographer and he's responding to this
um Scientific American story called a
secret weapon and preventing the next
pandemic fruit bats
um he says the title appears to promote
a better appreciation of bats however
the next sentence mistakenly claims that
bats worldwide are primary transmitters
of viruses deadly to humans
the flawed conclusion reached a
worldwide audience in 2017 through a
study that reported more viruses and
bats than in other mammals it examined
nearly twice as many bats as all other
animals combined ignoring the fact that
new viruses can be found wherever we
look nevertheless it receives
Sensational media coverage worldwide in
contrast a far more thorough study
concluded that bats did not Harbor more
viruses than other animals but continues
to be mostly ignored as evidenced by the
recent Scientific American article the
scary sensationalist study continues to
dominate public perception of bats
so I thought I'd look at what the
original 2017 study uh was and what the
laters it turns out 2020 study was the
2020 study uh is by a team of
researchers I don't recognize the 2017
study uh which is the piece of evidence
that has since been debunked that is the
basis on which we are blaming bats for
things was published by a team that
includes Peter dessick oh my god oh so
perfect it's perfect it's perfect global
patterns and coronavirus diversity
publishing virus Evolution that is the
basis on which now Scientific American
and the whole damn world is blaming bats
because they're a really easy culprit
right blaming bats for our own uh
arrogance
and so this this is the this is the
perfect
um
uh link with Barrack because Barrick is
here creating fantasy stories completely
unscientific anti-scientific fantasy
stories
about how it is that this terrible virus
got into people when in fact how did it
get into people you Dr Barrick that's
how I got into people you figured out
how to do this and whether you actually
wielded the pipette or it was done in
Wuhan doesn't make any goddamn
difference this was your boilerplate
piece that was posted in all of your
Grant applications and all of the
Publications that came from them
swearing that your work was the thing
that was going to prevent the pandemic
it was the arrogance that allowed you to
believe that that [__] was true that
actually created the pandemic and you
can blame the bats you can blame
pangolins you can blame Frozen ferret
Badgers but the fact is it was you it
was fauci it was dazik it was Anderson
right these people are you know from no
CM edits to cover up these are the
people who make this possible and by
hiding what happened you're making it
certain it's going to happen again and
in the meantime you've unleashed
a novel virus on the world and uh we'll
never get rid of it which we're stuck
with yeah we're stuck with it uh and um
it's Unforgivable
honestly well let's put it this way uh
owning up to what you did uh would be a
start and you owe it to us whether or
not it's forgivable
yeah
all right well that was exciting mm-hmm
so uh we I think have reached the end
for today uh we'll be back on Saturday
with another live stream to make up for
the one that we lost last week and
hopefully your voice holds
I I think it will I think it will uh we
have a private q a this weekend at our
locals we encourage you to join us there
uh we also have um
the watch party right now is happening
at locals and lots of other good stuff
as well got a lot of great guest
episodes coming out right now
uh always check out when I'm writing
Natural Selections and
um I don't have any uh I don't have any
darker swag to show but we got the store
that's that's cool that's got great
stuff we've got a bunch of new a bunch
of new things coming out soon
there and oh I heard
I heard that there were no more signed
copies of our book available at
darvill's here in the San Juan Islands
and it turns out that is true and the
thing that is stopping us from signing
more copies because the owner of
Darwin's very much wants to have signed
copies apparently it's only like
you know books I like hotcakes but it's
selling very very well there of course
the book is 100 gather's guide to 21st
century is available everywhere um 10
seconds coming out and check very soon
um but but you can get signed copies at
darvels except right now and the thing
that's keeping us from them because
we're just a short fairy right away is
the fact the fairies aren't running very
well because uh the governor of the
state of Washington is an idiot that is
basically why there are no side copies
of our bucket travels at the moment but
there will be again soon
okay
um
check out our wonderful sponsors this
week MD hearing Sundays and Seed we will
put links to everything we talked about
here in the show notes as always and
remember that we are supported by you we
are very grateful to you our audience we
appreciate you subscribing to both
Rumble and joining us on locals sharing
uh both our full episodes and clips that
you will find
and
um and remember until we see you next
time to be good to the ones you love eat
good food and get outside be well
everyone
thank you
foreign